الركوب الأول هو الركوب المستقيم على الحائط ،
الفصل الثاني هو الكارت الصغير الخاص بنا ، لذا فهو عبارة عن
أربع عجلات هذه
المرة في واحدة من هؤلاء السيدات الجميلات
وعندما
ترفع يديك ، ارفع يديك عن الجلوس على
الجانبين واقفًا على الجانب كما  مجموعة كاملة
من الأعمال ، إنها تجربة
لا يمكنك تحضير أي شيء في العالم أيضًا
أنا كيري كاميرون والجدار الحديدي للموت
رايدر وأنا أركب جدار الموت الأصلي للوك فوكس ،
لقد بدأت في كتابة
جدار الموت بالصدفة البحتة.  اعتدت العمل
مع الخيول وللأسف حيث
كنت أعمل في المكان مغلقًا ،
لذلك من الطبيعي أن نذهب إلى Jobcentre وكتبت
للتو متسابقًا على الحصان في المحرك الثالث
وسنكون متسابقًا مختلفًا
ونزلت إلى الفناء و  لقد كان
لديهم جدار مرتفع كنت أعرفه هناك ، ثم
هذا ما
كنت تفعله ، تشعر بالدوار الشديد عندما
تصل طيورك الأولى لأنك قمت ببناء
هذا في الأسفل حتى الشعور بالدوار الذي
يجب أن تقطع مسافة 30 ميلاً في الساعة على الأقل
للبقاء مع الجاذبية
وإلا ث  تركك مباشرة ، إنه
شيء خالٍ من المزيج ، لذا فإن سرعة التوازن
وسأرى القليل من القدرة على التحمل بمجرد
رفع ذراعك ، إنها طريقة للتحيز الجيد ،
الجمهور يعد إنجازًا رائعًا ، إنه شعور جيد
أن تكون متسابقة أنثى في هذه
البيئة الرجالية  إنه يعطيني ضجة كبيرة
لأن الكثير من الناس عندما
يرونك تمشي في الحائط
يعتقدون أنهم قليلًا من الفلاش كما تعلم ،
ولكن بمجرد أن يروا
أنك تركب الدراجة ، يمكنك سماع مثل همهمة تقول لا
هناك فتاة على دراجة نارية ترى كل
وجوههن تضيء وبعد
العرض كل الفتيات اللواتي يعجبهن ، واو ،
لديك كرات وورود أكبر وبعد
ذلك ولكن من الرائع أن تعرف أنه من
المحتمل أن يعيدوا التفكير في الفتوة إذا
يمكن أن تفعل ذلك ثم
[موسيقى]